il ya un peu plus de deux ans le 4 avril
2010 est sarah et limite 65 ans médecin
puis directrice de crèche maman de trois
enfants de confession juive et roué de
coups puis défénestré de son appartement
de belleville jeté du troisième étage de
son immeuble par son voisin de 27 ans
kobe dit traoré c'est le nom de son
assassin il est interpellé puis placé en
hôpital psychiatrique car selon les
médecins celui ci aurait agi au coeur
d'une bouffée délirante et guy 2019
la cour d'appel de paris déclare qu
billy traoré pénalement irresponsable
les parties civiles décide alors de se
pourvoir en cassation
et hier la cour de cassation rend sa
décision et confirme l'arrêt de la cour
d'appel de paris qui déclare qu billy
traoré pénalement irresponsable si ce
n'est tous tombés des nues
forcément on a tous suivi le procès de
ce meurtrier et franchement moi j' ai
pas cru au départ j'ai dit il ya dû
avoir une erreur j'ai dû mal lire qu'est
ce qui s'est passé cette décision allait
incompréhensible on va en parler avec
william attal le frère de sarah halimi
québec avec nous en face time avec meyer
habib qui est avec nous députés des
français de l'étranger et raquel garrido
qui lassé l'avocate qui vient c'est
raquel garrido est l'avocate avant tout
et merci en tout cas d'être là où je
vais d'abord je voudrais d'abord
entretenir avec le frère de sarah halimi
williams attal qui est avec nous en face
time qui nous fait l'honneur de
témoigner ce soir merci d'être là
william merci d'être avec nous je suis
non plus williams on a tous été ou très
haut pour la plupart amènent à tous
voilà tous ici on en a même parlé en
dans les coulisses de date de cette
décision de justice vous après avoir
vécu le drame qui est arrivé à votre
soeur de vivre ça aujourd'hui c'est j'ai
envie de dire cccc un double drame
alors là premier jeu
que je voudrais vous dire où et les gens
n'ont pas conscience
c'est que la dernière nuit de ma soeur a
été exceptionnellement terriblement
épouvantable d'abord parce que l abord
sachez qu'elle a été assassinée et c'est
tout à fait exceptionnel devant 20
témoins devant neuf policiers armés
jusqu'aux dents et qu'il ne savait pas
où se passaient l'assassinât et il faut
savoir que l'individu me suis comme
billy traoré qui a martyrisé ma soeur
pendant une heure qui lui a brisé à
coups de poing et à coups de pied à
coups de téléphone tous les os du visage
les bras les jambes
le rapport de topsy a été une calamité
pour nous à lire une calamité
cet individu mais je suis comme l'y
traoré n'a pas montré la moindre
humanité
parce qu'il a montré massacré matters
oui ça me rappelle effectivement
l'assassinât aussi de madame mireille
knoll
ça me rappelle aussi beaucoup
l'assassinât d'ilan halimi
à chaque fois la même le même lien
lui-même très commun une inhumanité 1 1
une attitude est inimaginable une
violence inouïe
c'est extrêmement rare que les témoins
dans une affaire d'assassinât sont plus
traumatisée que ce que que la famille
héééé on en est là on en est là ma soeur
a souffert le martyre vous m'entendez le
martyre une femme de 65 ans de 50 kg
elle recevait des coups de massue d'un
individu d'un mètre 90 mais pourquoi et
pourquoi monsieur hanouna pourquoi parce
qu'elle portait une perruque
parce que parce que les enfants de ma
soeur portait une kippa
pourquoi parce que parce que ces gens de
porter un chapeau
pourquoi l embêter personne elle aider
tout le monde et fait des des
prescriptions midi
elle partagé ce repas de shabbat avec
tous les voisins pourquoi pourquoi cet
individu il ya deux éléments
et c'est vrai que quand j'entends la
question où la réponse de madame garrido
excusez-moi j'ai corse peut-être son nom
mais elle connaît pas personne ne
connaît le dossier et c'est pour ça que
j'ai voulu en parler est venu vous vous
en parler d'abord cet individu faut
savoir il est c'est ses dix ans de
délinquance absolue ces 22 condamnations
justice c'est 50 gardes à vue c'est un
professionnel de la délinquance c'est un
trafiquant de drogue qui inondent
belleville en en cannabis
c'est ça et puis en même temps
malheureusement est bon il a fait 2 en
prison il a fait également deux ans de
prison
des séjours de trois mois de six mois et
et puis et puis en même temps les six
derniers mois personne le sait on l'a
appelé la cour d'appel on ne savait pas
personne nous l'a dit il allait depuis
six mois à la mosquée salafistes omar et
et le dernier jour il y ait ruinée a été
cinq fois et dit rester s'il ya 10
heures du soir
qu'est ce qu'il faisait à la mosquée
omar le dernier jour qu'est ce qu'il
faisait
et ensuite et ensuite et bien il est
parti au restaurant et comme vous et moi
donc il disait la juge qui n'avait plus
d'appétit et puis et puis ensuite il y
là il a décidé de manière tout à fait
anormal de ne de ne pas dormir dans
l'immeuble où habitait masseur puisqu'il
mtn deuxième étage et une troisième de
tout à fait anormalement il va dormir
chez son copain dans l'immeuble à côté
mitoyen deux immeubles collés l'un à
côté de l'autre
là c'est le début du drame parce que il
s'endort et puis à quiconque du matin il
prend il sort quines avec son
tapis de prière avec une tenue de
rechange ça me rappelle qu à ça ça me
rappelle une tenue un compte tenue de
jihadiste et puis là il se passe quelque
chose d'incroyable comme savoir la
configuration des sauces des immeubles à
tuer ma soeur pourquoi pas parce que il
y avait quinze mois d'août au troisième
étage un balcon qui était à la fois
qu'ils appartenaient qui était divisé en
deux divisé en deux la partie de ma
soeur sara halimi et l'autre partie
d'une famille malienne s'appelle la
famille dia tout rien pour être cédés
cela maintenant impossible impossible
on ne peut pas 15 mètres de hauteur
impossible la seule façon d'y accéder
c'est soit par la porte d'entrée de chez
ma soeur elle n'aurait jamais ouvert à à
4 heures du matin soit parce balcon que
fait l'assassin mais bizarrement est
tout à fait par hasard il va danser
cette famille s'en tapait aucune porte
il a dit à la juge d'instruction qu'il
ne savait pas où il allait ou c'est
parce qu'il faisait et où ils arrivent
ils frappent à la porte
il frappe à la porte et il dit à
monsieur diarra qui est qui porte le
même nom que sa mère bizarrement son
monde le nom de jeune fille de sa mère
et qui est un et qui est aussi un ami de
la famille et qui vivait dans le même
village que toute la famille de traoré
ouvre moi ces conneries me suis dire à
l'humour est là bizarrement il y aura ce
la clé les clés de son appartement il
ferme la porte à clés mis la clé dans sa
poche et il s'écrit ça va être la mort
ça va être la mort bizarre le matin si
vous l'êtes vous dire également il
rencontre ses parents et ses parents
répété à la juge d'instruction et à un
ami ne vous inquiétez pas j'ai tout raté
dans ma vie tu sur l'échec de lits mais
ce soir tout sera terminé par coûter moi
je suis tombé de ma chaise quand j'ai
enlevé plan quand je vois ça ne serait
ce pas dessiner des propos annonciateur
de l'assassinât et ensuite ils rentrent
dans l'appartement il va dans la cuisine
il fait ses ablutions des mains et
ensuite il s'agenouille et le commence à
réciter des sourates du coran
et puis bizarrement encore bizarrement
il dirait juge d'instruction
besoin d'aller au balcon attaque il a
éprouvé le besoin alors oui là il dit à
la juge j'ai aperçu le porte fenêtre de
madame halimi ouvert impossible la nuit
à 4 heures du matin tout noir avec eux
avec la l'épaisseur des débats locaux
impossible de voir un paisible et il a
dit bah écoutez j'aperçus l'appartement
le portefeuille est ouvert un peu s'il
veut voir
j'y suis allé et j'ai été massacrés ma
soeur alors pour répondre à madame david
o pensez vous madame gallego ou des
rideaux que que cet assassin est arrivé
par hasard à 4 heures du matin en
changeant de l'immeuble en faisant
autant que circonvolutions chez ma soeur
alors william répondre non non on va
m'en bas william a donné là on va donner
la parole à raquel garrido
oui me le permet je termine s'est ravisé
rue diable c'est très important qu'il va
lui dire c'est très important je termine
je termine il y a donc préméditation il
n'est pas arrivé par hasard chez les
masses heures à 4 heures du matin c'est
impossible statistiquement impossible
j'étais professeur de maths madame de
rideau c'est impossible
donc s'il a prémédité et ça vous le
savez vous devriez le savoir il y a il y
à une contradiction entre la
préméditation et l'abolition du
discernement donc en fait
en fait si on avait reconnu la
préméditation
on ne pouvait plus dédouaner de sa
responsabilité
un assassin c'est à ça ça ne pouvait
plus donc on est dans une erreur
judiciaire majeur oui mais ensuite je
sais ce que vous allez me dire banale
garrido vous allez me parler des trois
expertises et j'ai beaucoup de choses à
vous expliquer sur cette initiative
j'ai strictement bien sûr je m'excuse je
vous laisse répondre
williams williams juste moi vous avez
vous avez parlé de passion de l'absence
de discernement qui a été retenue juste
il était aussi retenu que c'était un
crime antisémite
voilà donc comment on peut avoir une
absence de discernement
c'est quand on sait qu'on fait un crime
antisémite donc là c'est un problème là
quels moyens peux me permettre
il ya quelque chose qui me permet
dérange monsieur hanouna oui je peux me
permettre
il ya encore des éléments que vous
n'avez pas dans ce dossier où beaucoup
d'experts judiciaires se sont prononcés
éminent ils ne savent pas que la juge
d'instruction d'abord à l'appui quelque
chose d'extrêmement grave
elle a empêché une reconstitution ça
c'est un pur sang des affaires
criminelles
elle s'est battue de toutes ses forces
une reconstitution aurait apporté la
preuve choix de la culpabilité de la
préméditation de la tasse à l'après midi
à sion soit la preuve du contraire
pourquoi s'est elle opposée à une
reconstitution
pourquoi la juge d'instruction a
également a également s'est opposé à
dans toute enquête criminelle ça c'est
100 % des cas on enquête sur le
téléphone portable de l'assassin on
track ga toutes les affaires criminelles
c'est horrible dans toutes les enquêtes
criminelles le compte facebook de
l'assassin et s'étudier oms a retrouvé
le compte facebook de la sarre vous
savez comment il s'appelle mais monsieur
oublie traoré sur son compte facebook du
poteau eh ben ils s'appellent boubacar
sow fana il porte le même nom que
youssouf fofana
on est dans une situation incroyable où
deux fofana ou tuer deux halimi et vous
allez encore me dire que c'est un hasard
et vous allez encore me dire que c'est
un hasard
alors vous dire qu'on va avoir j'en
connais la réponse de raquel garrido
williams à quelques arrêts de jeu jean
prix excusez moi y'a pas de quoi vous
dire maria revenant sur quoi il ya
vraiment pas de quoi ses excuses à
monsieur vraiment c'est évidemment cas
pas à s'excuser
la peine la peine de la famille et est
beaucoup plus fort ce que dans d'autres
cas
parce qu'effectivement l'absence de
procès l'absence de condamnation
l'absence de punition dans ce meurtre
antisémite atroce est proprement
insoutenable
donc évidemment et j'entends très bien
où votre exposé est très clair et vous
ne croyez pas du tout à la thèse en fait
de la démence de la folie de la bouffée
délirante
vous pensez que c'est une erreur
judiciaire et visiblement vous avez
décidé de poursuivre votre action en
justice vous irez à la cour européenne
d'hommes et franchement c'est vous c'est
votre droit et vous avez raison de le
faire et vous avez si vous pensez que
des tas de juges d'état d'experts d'état
d'individus se sont trompés c'est votre
droit le plus strict et le plus absolu
de vouloir faire inverser le décidera de
justice madame garrido il n'y a pas de
il n'hésite pas à niveau de justice
comme ever il n'y a pas d'étapes
d'experts et puis il faut quand même
savoir qu'on est dans une situation
incroyable où l'expert qui a provoqué la
des responsabilités de la tête mais je
peux bensoussan et bien il a à la cour
d'appel reconnu devant cinquante
personnes qu'elle s'était trompée de
diagnostic que cet individu mais aucune
maladie mentale
c'est qu'elle vous connu malheureusement
on va me dire que c'est un hasard
oui